done a lot of awesome foundational work
uh on lock gift sampling over the years
and uh it's our pleasure to have him
go ahead or not
thank you very much
uh i would like to start by thanking the
organizers for this very nice workshop
unfortunately i couldn't go to berkeley
for being present in person
but having the opportunity to give a
talk via zoom is a good thing as well
so it's already evening in paris so i
might be a little bit tired
uh
but in any case if you have any question
please do not hesitate to interrupt me
during my talk and to ask the question
so the paper that i will present now
is about large one monte carlo for look
concave densities
the important point here is that there
is no
uh the word strong
in the title so we will be mainly
focusing on the case where the densities
look concave but it's not look strongly
concave
it's a joint work with my phd former phd
student avedik cara gulian
so let me
start very slowly by introducing the
framework
so the goal is
something which is i think very clear
for everyone in this audience
uh is to sample from a probability
density function which will be denoted
by pi theta
and it can be written via a potential
function which be denoted by f
so we will assume that the potential
function is defined on the whole space r
to power p
and we will also assume that this
function is convex
we will not assume strong convexity on f
but
in order to have some control on the
flatness of f
we will assume some bounded moment
assumptions and
uh more precisely we will denote by a mu
sub subscript q
the moment of order q of
the distribution pi and we will assume
that it's finite for q equal to two
and we will also need to have some
smoothness assumptions on f
uh the most natural smoothness
assumption here is just to assume that
the function f is gradient lip sheets so
it's just written here the the gradient
of f should be lipschitz and i i've
already said the function f has to
become x which means that
i mean if the second order derivative of
or the hasten matrix exists then it
should be definitely positive
there are many many natural examples
appearing in statistics which satisfy
these assumptions
and the
same placed one is probably the
multivariate logistic regression one can
easily check that if your one is in the
multi-dimensional setting uh the reduce
regression
uh if one uses the
bison approach and defines the posterior
distribution function it will be lock
concave but it will not necessarily be
look strongly concave
so what is the goal in this work and in
this talk
uh so the goal is just to find the
distribution u
such that it is easy to sample from mu
and we have
some guarantees uh
indicating that the search time distance
between u and pi is small
let me just do two very small remarks
here
first of all we can have a very naive
sampler with just samples zero edge
iteration and i mean constantly zero
in this case it is clear that the vassar
stein distance between
the sampler and the target will be
bounded from above by this quantity mu
of q
and
i will go back to this point in a few
slides but the goal that we will have
here
is to
uh
to try to do so that
we get an accuracy which is epsilon
times the the accuracy of this naive
sampler
and
an interesting feature of the log
concave densities there are many
interesting features for low concave
densities but
one particular feature which is also
very useful in the context of sampling
is that all the moments are equivalent
in other words
there are some constants a q of course
they depend on q and they do not depend
on the probability distribution pi
such that the
so the the moment of order q
is upper bounded by this constant a
cubed multiplied by the second order
moment of pi
okay
so for instance
uh so this inequality was known long ago
we can uh so it's it can be proved using
a very famous borel inequality
uh
but we did some
a little bit tedious work
in order to figure out
uh what is the real order of magnitude
of the constants involved in this
inequality and it turned out that just
curiosity for q equal to three a q is
smaller than 3.5 for q equal to 484.6
and we have a complicated formula
involving the incomplete gamma function
which allows us to compute these values
for
every queue
so it's a small contribution of our
paper i wanted to mention it right away
but it's just
a small curious fact
now what we will
be studying in this paper and in this
talk
are
mcmc methods which are based on the
evaluation of the gradient of the
potential function so i will refer to
these methods as first order mcmc
methods
uh doing the parallel with first order
optimization
and
perhaps the most natural candidate for
approximating the distribution pi here
is the larger than monte carlo method
so the definition of the launch one
monte carlo i guess has been already
given uh during yesterday's talk and
most of
people present in the audience know this
definition
here i just wrote the definition in
order to uh to show notations that i
will be using throughout this talk
so theta k
will be the state of the of the mcmc
process that i will be uh studying
uh h usually will denote the step size
so it will be small a small parameter
k will be the number of iterations
and
x i will denote the innovations the
random innovations that we are adding to
the gradient descent in order to
make it stochastic and to make it
converge
to a distribution instead of converging
to the single point which is the
minimizer of f
okay so here for the larger monte carlo
the innovations are iiv gaussian with 0
min and identity covariance matrix
and also i will denote by mu
the distribution of
different monte carlo algorithms so new
subscript k will mean that it's the mcmc
iterated k times
and
is the superscript usually i will try to
write that the name of the algorithm
so this is the standard lmc
it will be one of the candidates who
will be studying
the second interesting candidate is the
largemouth monte carlo with averaging
it's a very it's a very simple one and
can be seen as a particular case of the
lmc what uh one has to do is simply
draw
a random variable tau
which is uniform between one and k so
uniform on this
uh discrete set
and then once this two is computed we
just compute the lmc
up to time two okay so the average lmc
will be just
a randomly chosen
uh iterate of the lmc algorithm
so why do we call
this algorithm
long or average large one monte carlo
it's simply because if you look at the
distribution of this algorithm so at the
distribution of site k a l m c
you can see that it's equal to the
arithmetic mean
of
mu 1 mu 2 up to nu k where new k is the
distribution of the original lmc
a third algorithm that is studied in
this framework
is the so-called kinetic large van monte
carlo which is also known as underdumped
london monte carlo so the complicated
formula is written here
it's not very important to understand to
to parse this formula the important
point is that the iteration k plus 1 is
defined as
a mean
which involves the gradient of f
plus
a gaussian
vector
and these gaussian vectors are also iid
and one has to write the coherence
matrix of these gaussian vectors i
didn't write it here because it's a
little bit complicated but there is a
precise form for this covariance matrix
as well
and of course for all the methods which
are written here we can also use the
metropolis hastings adjustment of these
methods uh in this talk i will only
focus on the case of the lmc so the
metropoli metropolis has things
adjustment of the lmc which is
called in the literature m-a-l-a so mala
okay so what the air
this is different kind of mcmc are doing
if we draw the picture in the one
dimensional case we can surround
different paths of this uh markov chains
and
go up to time say 30 to see
where they arrive and if we see the
positions of the particles up to time t
and we draw the histogram of of these
positions we can see that these
histograms are close
to a
probability density function and here
this probability density function will
be
equal to the target density pi
so the main goal that we have here is to
evaluate the number of
uh gradient evaluations which are
sufficient
for getting an epsilon accuracy
of course we want to understand how this
number depends on epsilon but also how
this number depends on the dimension
and how this number depends on the
condition number i will go back a little
bit later to
uh to what the condition number is it's
not
i mean it's easier to understand in the
case of strongly low concave densities
it's a bit more trickier for
uh
densities which are low concave but not
strongly low concave
so the important quantity that we are
trying to control here is the mixing
time
so if we have a given algorithm
and we use the wasserstein distance w2
then the mixing time will be defined as
a smaller integer
such that if we do k iterations of the
algorithm
then we will get a probability density
function which distance to pi is smaller
than epsilon times the moment of order q
of pi
so this quantity will be the main
quantity of interest in this work
and let me
start
now i mean let me give now a quick
overview of the results before going to
the details
as i have already told we want to
understand the order of magnitude of
this k the mixing time
and this table here
describes very quickly how this quantity
k depends on
dimension p
the precision epsilon
and
the condition number kappa
and you can see on the top uh left
corner of the table here the definition
of the
condition number kappa so we define it
as
the leap sheets constant m
multiplied by the second order moment
squared divided by dimension
so this definition is convenient for
several reasons first of all
uh if we use this definition then kappa
is environment by scale change so if
instead of
uh sampling from pi
we want to sample from a distribution
which is just
obtained from pi by a change of scale
then this kappa will be exactly the same
so it will not change
and the second reason for using this
kappa is that in the strongly log
concave situation one can check
that mu2 squared is equal to the
dimension divided by the strong
convexity constant
okay so
if we replace mu2 squared by p divided
by strong convexity constant we obtain
here
capital m divided by
uh say small m which is the strong
convexity constant and this is exactly
the definition of the
condition number in the strongly
low concave situation
okay so just
keep in mind that we are using this
definition of kappa and with this
definition of kappa which was already
done in the literature
uh is bounds on the total variation
distance
so these results are written on the
bottom line of the table
the first row is the result for the
large one monte carlo with averaging
this result has been obtained in a very
nice paper by georgia's majesty and
mercedes
and it has a very nice dependence on
dimension and on
on the accuracy so on epsilon
and also a very
nice point in this result of this first
column
is that
the
numerical constants are given explicitly
and they are really reasonably small
so this is an important point for me
because
basically when i started to to work on
mcmc's the main reason for me to to to
get interested in it was that some of
the students came to me and said okay i
have an mcmc algorithm i want to
approach some density and i don't know
how many steps should i perform in order
to attain
given absolute accuracy
and the uh so the student was often
asking me whether there is a theoretical
way of defining the number of iterations
of course it is closely related to the
convergence diagnosis of mcmc algorithm
and when i really looked through the
literature i i saw and it was a little
bit surprised for me
that there were almost no result that
could be used even in the simplest
situation even for getting some numbers
which are very very high it was not
really possible to to get results
and we know by now that is a strongly
uh
low concave situation we can have
such results and the goal of this paper
is also to to get such results for low
context situations in which we have
explicit constants everywhere and nice
dependence on different parameters
so for the lmca there is this result for
the total variation distance for mala
there is this
second column
which is derived from the paper by the
ital
and i should mention here that
the speed is
very good especially dependence on
epsilon is very uh very good better than
all the others
but this result comes without explicit
constants and if we try to
uh to obtain constants there they are
really very large
and finally the
the the two last columns of the table
uh the first two rows are the results
that we obtain in our paper
and the
results of the last row on the third
column
was in in the or my original paper of
2017
on the launch on monte carlo for
strongly low concave distributions
okay i will come back to this table a
little bit later on to compare different
results
let me
move forward now
so
in order to
handle the
case of low concave distributions which
are not strongly low concave i will
present here three main approaches one
could think of
and i will try to compare to say which
are the weak and strong points for each
of these approaches
are there any questions so far
no okay so
i can continue
uh first of all there is a very simple
proposition which uh
which is simple to prove so i gave a
sketch of the proof here but let us just
read the statement of the proposition it
tells us that if we are interested in
the vassar's time distance of order q
for any q which is larger than one
we can bound this vasserstein distance
using
any bound on the total variation
distance
so we simply need to bounce the total
variation and
moments of the distributions mu and u
prime of order r
where r should be larger than q
basically the best bound is obtained
when
uh r tends to infinity because then the
the power power of total variation
distance
becomes
the the largest
one over q
but then the constant which is in front
which corresponds to moment of order r
explodes because these moments usually
go to the infinity
so there is
the proof uh the value of proof here but
in the interest of time i think that i
will not spend time on that
um
just
let me mention here that
if we
uh
use
this inequality
in the case where one of these two
distributions is low concave then of
course as i have already mentioned the
moment of order r can be upper bounded
by the
second order moment
and if we assume that the other
distribution has a
uh say for instance first order moment
which is not larger than the second
order moment of the target distribution
then
we can relate
the mixing time in vasserstein one
distance to the mixing time into total
variation distance
and basically it simply says that if we
want
uh
the
mixing time in w1 distance we need to
compute the mixing time
of
total variation distance not at epsilon
but at epsilon divided by a r to this
power which is close to one
and recall that a r was the constant
which was involved in the comparison of
moments for low concave distributions so
usually a r goes to infinity when r
goes to infinity
uh okay so we have these two results
written
here the one for w1 the one for w2 and
the important thing uh to to notice is
that for w1
uh we have we should have the total
variation distance bounded by epsilon to
power one plus something
for w2 it should be epsilon
to power two plus something okay
so there is a power two
uh popping up here
and if we use these results
in
combination of the last row of the table
so we can easily see that from the last
row which are bounds for the total
variation distance we can
infer
bounds from for for w1 and for w2 so the
formulas which are written here in red
are complicated so i will not read the
formulas i will just quickly comment
them
so what we see
for instance compare
the
first
so the second row and second column yeah
and
i assume that r is equal to infinity and
forget about the the factor
a r to power eight so what we get here
is p squared over epsilon eight
which is worse than the p squared over
epsilon six
that we get by our method that i will
describe later
uh
for
mala
it's a little bit different once again i
have said that mala uh behaves very well
as
a function of epsilon so here we see
this behavior we have epsilon to power 3
instead of epsilon to power 6 or to
power
5
but the dependence on p is the worse the
dependence on dimension here is p to
power three and once again uh there is
this constant a r to power three which
pops up here which also can be very
large
uh yeah numerical constants also are
uh not very good for malware here
okay let me now talk about the the
second approach
which is based on poincare inequality
so i recall here that
a function
sorry a density function prime satisfies
the poincare inequality if uh such an
inequality satisfied for every function
edge which is local ellipses and uh
integrable squared integrable
so what's important here is the constant
cp which is in front of the integral
here
and of course we are
interested in having distributions for
which this constant cp is as small as
possible
a very
nice fact about low concave
distributions is that
any log concave distribution satisfies
the pawn car inequality
uh which basically means that cp is
finite for every low concave pi
but
what's less uh
i mean what's a bit annoying here is
that
uh we know that this constant cp is
finite
but we
don't really know what is the order of
magnitude of cp
of course there is this famous kls
conjecture which
uh if it's true it helps to understand
the order of magnitude but uh
even in that case we don't we cannot
really i mean there are no
easy way to evaluate this constant cp
for a given distribution pi
uh
so it's only so so why this point array
inequality and the blackboard constant
is interesting
in the framework of sampling because
the prank array constant
is exactly equal to the spectral gap of
the transition operator so to the
inverse of the spectral gap of the
transition operator
and therefore there is an inequality
which says that if we
consider the distribution of the larger
one diffusion at time t so let us call
it new subscript t
then the distance between
mu t and the target distribution pi
decreases exponentially fast
so the rate of the
exponential decay is one over cp okay so
here cp is a one card constant
so using this kind of algorithm there
are several papers that establish the
results for uh sorry using this kind of
argument there are several papers that
have established guarantees for
something algorithms here i mentioned
perhaps the
most recent paper
which uh
which is a paper by lehey comes there is
this here m3 which says that if the
target distribution pi is low concave
and the potential function f is limits
with constant l and
uh be careful here l is not the capital
m because i was using capital m for the
leap sheets constant of the gradient of
f but here only the function f is
assumed deep sheets the gradient is
simply assumed
locally lip sheets and the constant
doesn't matter there
so their result says that if the step
size is reasonably small then there is
uh this bound here
for the search term two distance
i'm sorry there is a small typo here
this should be vassar sign distance
squared here okay so the vassar
sign distance squared is upper bounded
by this quantity and we see that this
upper bound
uh
contains explicitly the dependence on
the
step size h or the number of iterations
k which is present in the both terms
here
and also it involves the lipsticks
constant l and the the poincare constant
p and the chi square divergence between
the
uh the initial point
mu zero and pi
can be upper bounded as well in the case
where the initial point is chosen as a
gaussian distribution with the center
the minimum point of the
potential function um
yeah uh so we're having some uh audio
difficulties with the speaker uh do you
mind giving us a few seconds to uh
thanks so much
this
check check one
two right i think we're up and running
again if you want to continue
yeah okay so
should i uh repeat some parts or i can
resume from the point where i was
okay i assume that i can just continue
um
so there is this result obtained by jose
flake and if we use this result and
compute the mixing time we get something
which is proportional to the planck are
a constant to the power 3 multiplied by
l squared dimension square divided by
epsilon to power 4.
so once again if we compare
uh with uh the table presented above we
see for instance the dependence on
dimension is approximately the same the
dependence on epsilon is to power four
so it's not better than uh what we have
here
uh
and
the annoying thing is that there is this
point constant which pops up here
uh which might depend on p and for which
we don't have
any good control as for now
and another
annoying point is that the function f is
assumed to be global leap sheets which
might be violated in some situations in
a very simple case if you assume a
gaussian distribution
with
degenerate coherence matrix
then the function is not globally
lip sheets it's globally gradient
limited but it's not globally lipids
so
let us move to the third approach
that we have used in our paper and which
is a probably the simplest approach
it is based on the convexification trig
just to to explain it let me mention
that if the function f if the potential
function f
is alpha strongly look concave
then
uh one can show
that the poincare constant is smaller
than one over alpha okay so
uh
one can replace in the exponential
convergence the poincare constant by one
over alpha and it is also known for
instance it can be found in the book by
cedric vidani that
for the continuous time diffusion
process largely diffusion process the
distance between the distribution at
time t on the target distribution pi
uh satisfies this simple inequality here
so the goal
uh the idea of this third approach is
just to add the quadratic penalty to the
potential function
so that this new potential function
uh becomes strongly convex and we can
apply this kind of exponential
inequalities to this panelized
potential function so we will denote the
strength of the penalty
by alpha
we will also often call alpha the
penalty parameter
and
the new target distribution that we get
using this panelized potential will be
denoted by pi alpha
and a first result that we have
established is that
the
distance between pi and pi alpha can be
easily upper bounded as a function which
goes to zero when alpha goes to zero
for total variation distance it is just
upper bounded by a function which is
linear in alpha for uh
the vassars line distance of order q
so the distance is upper bounded by
alpha to power one over q okay because
here on the
uh left hand side we have the power q of
the vassar's time distance and we have
also all the explicit constants in this
inequalities for
search time one distance is equal to 22
for instance
okay
uh from now on when we
talk about alpha lmc it's simply this
large one monte carlo method which is
applied not to the function f but to the
function f alpha to the panelist
potential
and how to analyze such a method
the the basic tool of the analysis is
just the triangle inequality which says
that if we
uh
compute the distance between the
panelized
launchpad monte carlo the target
distribution is smaller than the sum of
these two distances
uh where
for the first distance is just
uh the quality or the the precision of
sampling from a strongly look concave
distribution okay so this first distance
here is something which has been uh so
early started in the literature over
past say five years and there are many
different results in different settings
for bounding this term and the second
term is bounded in the proposition which
is just written above
so
if we use this approach and i give here
uh we can of course obtain plenty of
results in many different settings under
different conditions on f
uh
in the the the simplest result which is
about the alpha lmc is the one
uh written here
which says that this penalized
lmc has an accuracy which is upper
bounded by three terms there is a first
term which goes exponentially fast to
zero
uh the second term
is the discretization error which is
zero when this
step size h is equal to zero and the
third term
is the term which is due to the penalty
so this term is zero if there is no
penalties if alpha is equal to zero
so very often when i show this result
people ask me why do we have alpha
present in the second term second term
accounts for the discretization error
and one could think that introducing
this penalty alpha doesn't change the
properties of the path of the diffusion
process
so the discretization error shouldn't
change
but the fact is that
we
compute here the discrete the
discretization error
after k steps
and so the number of steps we are
executing here
will depend on alpha
and since the number of steps depends on
alpha uh the discretization error
depends itself on alpha here okay so we
have to
uh
divide here by alpha and it's present
also in all the
remaining results
any anyway we can
uh use this upper bound for optimizing
with respect to alpha and with respect
to h so first of all we choose alpha so
that this last term is small and once
alpha is
fixed we just minimize the sum of the
first two terms with respect to h
and doing that
we get some
simple upper bounds for the mixing time
for w1 distance and for w two distances
these bounds are written here
and what we saw already in the table
earlier where exactly these bounds
without the constants and without the
logarithms just the simplified forms of
of these inequalities
uh there is exactly the same form of
upper bound for the kinetic lunge one
monte carlo penalized by this quadratic
penalty as well
of course here c3 the situation is a bit
harder from a technical point of view
because
there is this friction parameter gamma
which is also
entering into the play
and we optimize with respect to all
these parameters alpha gamma and h
the upper bounds that we get
depend have a better dependence on
dimension better dependence on
epsilon and the constants numerical
constants are smaller as well
the only point where they are a bit
worse than previous results
or is the dependence on the condition
number
unfortunately the condition number here
which is is this m times mu squared to
power
3 over 2
is worse than the dependence for the
previous result and
so i think that this is mainly due to
the fact that for the k
lmc
uh
the results um the dependence of the
existing results in the strongly convex
situation
are
perhaps more optimal with respect to the
condition number
okay so
since i'm running out of time let me
conclude
so in this work
we analyze the situation of
log concave densities and how we can
sample with some
precise theoretical guarantees
from these distributions
in the case of gradient lipschitz
potentials
and we have shown that the simple
convexification trig is still
competitive with all the other natural
approaches
but of course the literature of this
topic is very rich and it has grown very
fast over past years so it might very
well happen that there are some results
that i am not aware of so if
some of you in the audience
have some result or can
point to some results that i missed in
this overview i will be very happy
in our paper we have also similar
results under additional assumptions
specifically in the case of hessian leap
sheets potential
and now we are working in improving
these results by choosing variable step
sizes h k and also variable head of
penalty levels alpha k
and
to the best of my knowledge
uh the
discretization method which leads to the
best results for lmc and for klmc
is the midpoint discretization
introduced by shannon lee in their paper
of 2000 2019
so our goal is to combine these three
points in order to get improved results
and the first step that we did in this
direction uh was in a paper written with
avedik aragorn and published in europe's
last year where we considered the
continuous time process with uh variable
penalty level alpha t and we have proved
that if we choose this alpha t
as
so
morally inversely proportional to t
then the w2 distance becomes inversely
proportional to square of square root of
t
so we have this uh nice results for
continuous time diffusion process now
the goal is to discretize it and
we believe that using midpoint
discretization we will get the best
results for this
so thank you very much i would like just
to finish with an announcement i have a
postdoc position in paris if some of you
are interested in of or you have friends
or students who are interested in
please feel free to send me an email
thanks a lot
um
okay cool oh yeah thanks a lot arnock um
and i guess we have time for a few
questions before uh taking a break for
the next speaker
oh yes
and hi not this is jensey uh very nice
talk
i just want to have one comment
on the table for mala i think
under your weekly log concave case
the rate for mala has been improved
since dvd and r should have p square
instead of t cube
then will be comparable with other
algorithms
i can send you an email later to clarify
yeah
yeah thank you
[Music]
um any other questions
yeah i have a question
um
um
you say that uh under kls and the
quakaiko start could not be related to
the
like to anything tractable isn't it like
the poincare constants would be like
uh proportional to the variance or
something
again
so what i was simply saying is that um
i i
don't really know whether we can
something really numerically computable
for the power for the company
[Music]
of the korean operator right
yes so this is something that
we could be able to compute
but then there is a constant in the kls
yeah
again
you may choose not to answer any
question for any reason okay you may
also all right thank you
um
okay great i guess uh we're a bit over
time so let's maybe take other questions
offline and uh take a break for the next
speaker
thank you very much